si on s'interroge vraiment sur ce qui me
mener à ces violences il ya plusieurs
choses il ya d'une part la lune viande
une violence presque structurel de la
police française et puis d'un autre côté
lorsqu'on on énonce le cv de délinquant
des uns et des autres peut-être si on
s'intéresse réellement au racisme on
peut se poser la question de savoir
pourquoi pourquoi en fait on trouve plus
de délinquance chez les populations
défavorisées c'est la réponse est
extrêmement simple c'est à dire que plus
de pauvreté plus de plus d'injustice et
on est en fait évidemment que si on
prend si on si on circule socialement
dans danser danser on circule
socialement on voit bien que la
délinquance avait associé à la pauvreté
donc la logique en fait le fait que les
gens et d aider casier judiciaire non
vierge est associée à leur condition
sociale et c'est très important de dire
aussi c'est à dire qu'ils ne font pas il
ne faut pas nier la délinquance il faut
il faut il faut se dire qu'elle est
qu'elle qu'elle fait qu'elle fait
quelques elle participe de cette de ce
système qu'il est injuste
[Musique]